red carpet ever I'm so much happier when
it's not my movie awesome I guess what
assume that you're like super dad and
very well-liked about your kids anyway
but does this make you cooler my son's
obsessed like he wakes up this place
Lego so yeah it was a big surprise I
flew back from Vancouver big boy yeah
and they didn't know so it's a pretty
rad morning to surprise them and then
all their friends do inside rather
friends you're like winning right now
dad goes right for sure you're also
winning because of the fashions now I
want to point out you always look
amazing but are you wearing like a
fashion scrunchie on your wrist I am
it's my favorite pink scrunchie I think
I just fell more in love with Jason
Momoa
I think I did oh and I scrunchie on yeah
I have some business to ask you about
first when Johnson wants you to be his
brother and you don't have time what's
going on yeah we tried to make it happen
I mean David Leitch is one of my mentors
he's kind of taught me for everything
that I know first fighting so we try to
work it out but I'm on my show so I know
super appropriate right but it was just
like yeah we're just like contracted can
Aquaman to update I hope so I mean we're
gonna show some when I come down I wanna
meet up and have a couple ideas I'm sure
they do and everyone's excited
everyone's really happy with the success
and I'm why wouldn't we do another one
just became King right now gotta do some
stuff
yeah let's make this happen Game of
Thrones was ending this year what do you
remember of your time on that show I
just I mean it was the prime years of my
life got a suspended on a really quality
show at beautiful people and and we're
all still family so I'm excited to go to
premiere on the third the last thing I'm
doing a Valentine's Day piece about how
Hollywood met their significant others
now I think you've told this story
before if you watch Cosby show you are
in love with Lisa but do you remember
the first time you actually met yeah
yeah I've talked about that moment too
but yeah absolutely I mean I don't want
to tell it again I talk too much but
yeah definitely fireworks I fell in love
yeah it was everything I wanted it to be
a more congratulation